let's talk about what's going on with
the with the press and waukesha we have
the story from the examiner
nbc labels waukesha attack an accident
oh it's better it's better we got it's
not just an accident it wasn't just a
guy on tv saying well you know the
accident here we've got cnn waukesha
parade crash suspect crash
is is is crash an intentional homicide
act okay i'll just jump over to google
vehicle plows through parade there's
times of india good on them cnn crash
fox says media blasted for calling it a
crash cnn waukesha crash eight-year-old
victim of the crash parade incident
parade incident bbc says
they are all terrified to say it was an
attack even though the dude's been
charged with intentional homicide i was
intentional homicide i believe right and
it was
i read just read the criminal complaint
that's
it's amazing to me because
you could have you have all of the
evidence and all of the elements in that
criminal committee that is a terroristic
criminal complaint the only difference
is that the charge isn't there and what
the police i guess is the chief of
police says at the press conference if
you had added up all of those facts and
you add in then one more paragraph of
the statements that he had made online
the years and years worth of statements
you know what you have
you have charlottesville yep you have
the charlottesville 2017 james fields
attack and they're all the same facts
imagine that they've found found similar
states except
that wasn't a christmas parade there i
mean so this is worse i mean
so the thing about charlottesville is
that you have two angry faces i'm
talking about from the complaint side
not the situation right right right uh
you have two fighting sides all day it's
nuts the cops aren't stopping and people
are did you cover that i was not
interested yeah no no
but a guy you know fired up gone at one
dude berkeley that
and then one guy's flame throwing
another guy and then a dude gets in his
car you had mutual combat
you're a lot of music oh definitely and
then uh i i can't speak to you know
what's going through people's minds but
i can tell you what the video shows
fields then starts driving down a road
towards a large group they run up and
start bashing his car and he just slams
the gas and rams into people
so there's a lot of heat of the moment
elements in that combat all day driving
down the road the dude slams the gas he
claimed i believe he was trying to
escape i don't think i believe him when
you have mutual combat and then a guy
engages in very serious attacks on
another group sorry you don't get that
benefit of the doubt but in in waukesha
he like see he he drove to a parade he
sought this out there was no combat here
it was little kids marching down the
street twirling batons and he plows
through him
this is
worse well so let me let me go read and
this is what i was getting at i have
the wikipedia articles and i
screenshotted these earlier today
here is the one for waukesha
2021 waukesha christmas parade car crash
on november 21st 2021 an suv was driven
through suv was driven through no name
of the driver the driven through the
annual christmas parade in waukesha
wisconsin almost makes it sound like
it's part of the parade it's so passive
right driven through the parade killing
six people and injuring 62 others then
we get the alleged driver of the vehicle
39 year old daryl lee brooks is in
custody brooks has been charged with
five degrees of first degree intentional
homicides actually hasn't been updated
because he's been charged with six now
yeah
once again wikipedia's fake news going
now i have i'll read this one there we
go
and this one and then the next one is
charlottesville
and of course i can't find it right now
so on in charlottesville though you get
the driver you get the fact that he had
made a series uh it starts by saying a
white supremacist yeah
oh here it is the charlottesville car
attack the charlottesville car attack
was a white supremacist terrorist attack
terrorist attack terrorist attack right
there perpetuated on august 12 2017 when
james alex fields jr deliberately drove
his car into a crowd of people
peacefully protesting the unite the
right rally in charlottesville virginia
killing one person and injuring 35. 20
year old fields had previously espoused
neo-nazi and white supremacist beliefs
and drove from ohio to attend the rally
so i think it's very important to point
out that this comparison intends uh the
intention is to show the waukesha
attacker
is comparable to what happened in
charlottesville a a someone who
committed a violent act against a group
of people
they're horrifying attacks but the media
over or like just just absolutely slams
charlottesville every moment they get
and waukesha i think yesterday cnn you
had a candidate in virginia that just
less what a week ago a month ago ran his
entire campaign was based around
charlottesville joe biden launched the
current president united states launched
his campaign based on charlottesville
this has been a seminal moment in
american politics well i think it's
fairly obvious
there are a bunch of people posting
about how they they they can assume uh
the race of the individual based on the
fact that the media won't report it and
it's actually uh not fair it's actually
it could be it's the coulter rule is
that what it is yeah they call or
coulter's law but but i think it's fair
to say if they don't report the race you
could just assume the person is not
white yes because it's not about any one
particular minority group it's just
about the the media has no problem
you know actually they enjoy saying like
a white person did this so you know
there a lot of people were pointing out
what do you think would happen in our
barrier every every moment of it what do
you think would happen if in the press
uh we had a story about a white man with
years of posts about how he doesn't like
black people gets in a car drives to a
black suburb and then rams a black
christmas parade what would the media
imagine if kyle rittenhouse had had
messages like that
right how right now didn't have
anti-black anything no no no no but i'm
saying if you did we would never have
heard anything but that for the entire
trial that's it right i mean the the
proud boys photo you get the one hand
gesture which you know
he even claims now was something that
was a setup he actually did claim that
in his last interview with um
with ashley banfield on uh on news
nation and uh i really like news nation
by the way a lot of stuff a lot of the
work they're doing i think they're
trying to kind of be what cnn was at one
point you know just kind of show both
sides and not really try to take a side
in 1991 yes
i mean like the original original
iteration watching those old keith
olbermann videos kind of sad to see how
psychotic i know right and then
you also of course had binger trying to
make use of kyle rittenhouse's social
media in the trial he bought he fought
for that uh that supposed proud boys
meeting photos he fought desperately to
get that into evidence no but he did use
his tick tock remember that oh yeah
that's the vo was your
tick tock account four doors you know
right yes
the only reason he was able to use that
was because kyle's
profile picture in there had him holding
right the rifle wow that's what made it
admissible i gotta give a shout out to
deborah messing
deborah messing yeah no wrong side of a
lot of things we're usually criticizing
her for but today she tweeted
dear mainstream media a man
intentionally drove a car through a
parade killing six and injuring 50 plus
it was not an accident fire emoji call
it by its name waukesha massacre and it
was a domestic terror attack don't
minimize police bravo
okay yeah
when the when celebrities and media are
lying and omitting and covering up and
then debra messing i mean look she's had
a lot of tweets i've been like oh geez
you know what what a crazy dude i'm
pretty sure she's been she's been on
suraj's list a couple times i'm sure she
has probably maybe not i don't know but
she came out she got it right and i i
completely agree she's right and then it
trended after that as well waukesha
massacre she started that she's i
believe she was the one who started that
trend and i think everybody wow was just
shocked that here's somebody who's you
know not not just known as you know your
typical prototypical hollywood you know
kind of lefty i mean she's like
like
blue and on like george takei
kind of just
occupied democrats i'm pretty sure
george doesn't actually run his own
twitter account i'm sure he doesn't i'm
sure he has a company do it and that's
why he sounds insane all the time yeah
and you're like
he's probably just sitting in a room
with like a warm blanket on his lap like
in the sun
half a sleep being old and someone's
tweeting away on his thing you know like
gravel institute you know mike gravel
you know right right right he passed and
now he's not even live anymore yeah yeah
right right right
so much for red flag laws then right
someone complains about you your
ex-girlfriend complains about you the
police come and take all your guns away
because you could be dangerous turns out
you don't need a gun to kill a bunch of
people you just you can just get a ford
escape and run it through a parade there
was someone who actually i always say
i mean this has been a talking point for
some time but the point i i bring up is
that every day you live in a city you
cross a street with these gigantic
multi-ton vehicles flying at you and
you're not scared of getting hit why
any one of those people could decide to
just hurt and kill dozens so new york
city of all places and they don't do it
it did happen a couple years ago it does
happen it did it it was like a house
happening a lot in the summer of 2015 or
16 in europe and this is interesting to
me because i remember how the bbc and
some of these over overseas
organizations characterized these
mysterious car attacks exactly like the
us media is characterizing this they
were literally terror attacks
perpetrated by foreigners who'd come
into like for example the uk and france
and they would not cover
where these people are coming from what
their ideologies might have been they
only covered that it was a car attack
the motive may never be known this is
why when you go to a christmas market
and tanya and i um a couple years ago we
were going through and visiting
christmas markets in europe that before
we had kids obviously and
there are barricades up before you can
go into in every country in europe with
the exception of poland not estonia well
in in europe right now i don't even know
who'd want to be there considering the
extremity uh
the lockdowns that's been happening not
poland and and not in poland thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you